you've got your accident on your page
the examples we were talking about
before the examples were going on for
let's get one of these pipe versus shoe
silence okay so we've got two axes here
each one is named after one of the
variables so I might have height every
year and shoe size now this is really
really important because when you have a
look this scatter plot that you're
looking at this is almost one but it's
got a pop in you're looking at looks
really similar to a dot plot after that
but isn't it full of thoughts and so we
get this on the right display what's the
difference
that's not a rhetorical question by the
way what is the difference between the
scatterplot you've got in front of your
music and the dots what's that we were
talking about before Jesus can work out
okay look what I don't know uh-oh
hold on careful careful when we draw dot
pops often we are the drawing with one
axis in fact that is helpful that I drew
earlier here in the quarter before I
just have one a success rate like the
scores get bigger and then you've got
doctor girl but another a second
vertical axis is implied just right here
right on a dot plot when you go up what
does that mean when you've got doctor
miss stepped up and longer really how
would that be see you again run it once
more you've got more scores right so for
example I could say RC is three four
five six is a score out of 10
and then if that goes really high that
means oh I've got lots of people who
scored 10 right so there anything what
does that mean we have a work that is it
starts with an F when you've got lots of
things if you frequently use right
so anyways you don't see it there is
always implied this vertical axis that
means frequencies that is not what's
going on here this vertical axis is
nothing to do with frequencies are
checking with how do I make it clear
then I got lots of ink results now just
draw this don't draw this because I just
want you to picture again I'm trying to
make a comparison because then the
coronary since they could they look at
difficult I'm not is it okay if you had
a Doppler and you had a whole bunch of
scores that were all on 10 right can
someone tell me it's not a trick
question I think about it can someone
tell me what would the difference be
between this dot here and this dot here
it would be a poly represents someone
else and other person's you've got that
but in terms of the score who is missing
that's why they're already here
okay now come back to excuse me come
back to you the scatter plot when you go
up and down there is a difference in
there if it was this over here up down
means what if something tire that means
that person is talk and if they're low
up then it means it's true so what are
we looking at here let's make this and
I'd like you to pick up your pen pencil
again this time let's make something
like this nothing else out this many
dots on it let's make this a scatter
plot
if you in a position like me and are
apart to make single dots on your pink
paper you might like to put X's at this
point through disillusionment
so yes I'm not giving you any numbers on
this you noticed or another what are we
looking at here so I'm trying to get a
relationship between shoe size and
height or do these things have anything
to do with each other
okay now on both if you double the one
that I've maybe factor which is quite
similar if you could describe I'm happy
food is your common sense with world
within the graph as height increases
what happens to shoe size
30p generally speaking it does seem to
also increase SS generally speaking okay
now this is not exactly like it's not
exactly line up if you've got two people
who are exactly the same height they
don't necessarily have exactly the same
shoe sales do there right so we would
say is it important phrase to have
underneath you we would say there is a
in this case moderates relationship
between whatever the variables are they
should look at you so I could say
there's a moderate relationship between
high and shoe size okay there's a creamy
relationship but it's not like you know
one or the other okay now we've got a
fancy word for this you actually don't
need to necessarily know it right now
but I want you guys to hear anyway
because it is the word that we use sorry
Rebecca this important word is
correlation for those of you are do I
think about it I know most of you who
are for those of you thinking that doing
standard next yuck this book word is a
really big deal because it's a huge
statistical contest
when you got two different things and
they're related in some way and we can
quantify this that's something you might
explore next year okay so let me just
recap this is a way represent done
justify the ways you seen before but the
big difference gears what's the big
difference
what's the big difference sign there
it's two variables right when we get off
down but let's write you're looking at
two completely different things okay
what do you stop represents in this case
hi exercise for this person or that
person or that person okay you can look
at now going to draw your attention back
to this you can see when you compare
some a scatterplot you don't always see
a relationship do you have a look at
that graph all the way over the right
hand side do you see that one
there's an ex very old is a Y variable
do you see why the shape tells you
there's not really any relationship at
all can you see why imagine if it were
hiking shoe size just imagine okay so
then you would look at all the people
who have this tall and you'd say what
are their shoe sizes look like they're
all over the place and you look at
people who are much shorter and you look
at their shoe size you'd say they're all
over the place right so it's not like
there's any close connection have a look
at B in the middle it's the opposite
what would you describe is happening
here you nation yeah this was inside
look it's going down okay so let's stop
in how about what would be something
where you increase one value and that
decreases another one how I look at the
board looking at something like this
what's something that might as
temperature increases what's something
that might decrease is things get hot up
I'm out of water yeah we I don't think
necessarily you get off up there
depending on the core dance with you
right how about this how about at each
of these dots were a date of the month
or something like that this might be
temperature and this might be say number
of soccer players out on the field
think about that when it's a really hot
day what did I tell you that the number
of soccer players won it's really small
you see it close to this axis right and
then as it gets cooler you get more and
more people playing soccer does that
make sense so it's a moderate
relationship or a tight relationship or
no relationship the last idea is there's
a direction right adjective for now this
wanders down what's our word for down
well negative right negative the other
one when it goes up is thank you
okay Brian got adjusted